un frío choque de puños dio inicio a un
polémico encuentro joe vice presidente
de eeuu y mohamed bin salman príncipe
heredero de arabia saudita finalmente
cara a cara las agencias de inteligencia
de eeuu señalaron a bin salman como
autor intelectual del asesinato del
periodista amalia en 2018
un hecho que alejó a ambos países tras
la victoria de bailén quien en su
campaña de 2019 prometió que haría pagar
un precio a los líderes del estado que
calificó entonces de faria el caso del
periodista salió a colación durante la
reunión y
aire al respecto al asesinato de hacks
ops y lo planté en un momento de la
reunión dejando claro lo que pensé en
ese momento y lo que pienso ahora es muy
franco y directo al discutirlo de que mi
punto de vista muy claro lo dije muy
claramente
fue un presidente de los estadounidenses
guarde silencio sobre el tema de los
derechos humanos es inconsistente con
quienes somos y con quién soy
quién fue la prometida de hudson y
publicó lo que supuestamente hubiese
tuiteado su pareja hola presidente está
la rendición de cuentas que prometiste
por mi asesinato la sangre de la próxima
víctima de mohamed bin salman está en
tus manos joe biden prometió poner el
tema de los derechos humanos en el
centro de su política exterior por lo
que su visita a arabia saudita resulta
polémica y desata reacciones incluso
dentro del propio partido demócrata
si alguna vez necesitamos un
recordatorio visual del control continuo
de los autócratas ricos en petróleo
tienen sobre la política exterior de
eeuu en el medio oriente lo tenemos hoy
un golpe de puño vale más que mil
palabras
joe biden quedó entre la espada y la
pared el acercamiento con riad se ve
impulsado por un complejo contexto
internacional con impactos internos para
eeuu donde la inflación es la más alta
en 40 años consecuencia del alza en los
precios de la gasolina el objetivo
principal de bailén sería pedirle a sus
socios del golfo que incrementen la
producción de crudo para mitigar los
costos de los combustibles